The Guardian has achieved great success from which it turned from a British newspaper to
One of the largest news sources in English in the world.
Guardian products are spread all over the world but we are really keen on
Reach beyond.
We have a great interest in the progress of space travel and space tourism
So the members of the engineering and design team are now testing how to develop great experiences
Which they receive on the planet and activate it anywhere you go to it even if in orbit, for example,
Or on the moon, or on a trip to Mars.
While testing our designs on the ground, we developed a system called Astro UI and implemented this system
Through all of our products we provide user experiences. The gloves in the additional vehicle mobility unit are very large
So we needed to design some new icons, specifically floating action buttons
We also used multidimensional design guidelines for this.
The other challenge we face in space is gravity, or lack of gravity. Using the principles of movement
We have created a system called Fixed Point View which leads to automatic alignment
For each of your articles, videos, and photos with the viewer no matter what your phone's status.
There are regular Android APIs that are very useful in space travel,
Especially the Text-to-Speech API. In space, you will sometimes be unable to look at the screen,
Therefore, the "Read it to me" feature is very useful. The astronauts can then
Listen to an article read through the helmet while they are on the moon, for example.
The test is really important because we need to identify the appropriate features and inappropriate features in space.
On Google Play Developer Console, there's a new feature called
hangout with expert.
Welcome, I'm Captain Mark Kelly how are you? Do you hear me?
This allows us to communicate face-to-face at any time with those who test the beta version in space
Whether on Earth or in space.
Travel to space is like going down fairly underground. Sometimes data charges are too high,
Sometimes data can not be obtained at all. The APK files we use are of a very small size
So they can be installed easily, and while these files are running we can cache as much content as possible.
Innovation is at the heart of the Guardian's work groups
All for the purpose of making our press service accessible to readers.
Now these experiments are no longer confined to the Earth, but extend beyond the earth as well.
Both Android and Google Play are key to achieving this goal.